-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy nominated actor
and comedian you know
from "Saturday Night Live"
as well as films such as
"Grown Ups," "Joe Dirt,"
and "Tommy Boy,"
plus "The Wrong Missy."
He co-hosts
"The Netflix After Party,"
which is currently streaming
on Netflix.
Please welcome back to the sho
our good friend David Spade.
How are you, David?
-I thought you were
looking for me to walk out
-It's weird, right?
That moment where you're
supposed to walk out?
-I'm usually
behind the curtain like this
[ Breathing rapidly ]
Hey!
Jump out.
Yeah, it's definitely weird.
It's definitely weird with
you don't have a crowd there
I don't have a crowd
in my house.
-It's weird times.
And you were starting a ne
show, "Netflix After Party,"
and I have to imagine
one of the hardest parts of it
is that you didn't get
to establish the baseline
of what it was like
with people in the audience.
Like, it's not easy for us
but at least we've got to do i
for a while with an audience
before we did it without.
How has it been?
-We started --
We started, yeah, without --
with nothing,
and then it was slowly
just trickling in the office
We've had one or two guest
come in.
They passed away
immediately after.
[ Laughter ]
No, they came in,
which was cool.
And then, you know, we hav
people on Zoom, and you do it.
And sometimes we have people
in Australia and,
you know, it's all the -- it's
like a hit show for Netflix.
We go over one show
each episode.
And if it's, you know,
"Bridgerton", they're in London,
and so you ask a question,
and it's literally
22 minutes later,
and then they answer.
You're on the next thing, you're
going, "They're answering!
[ Laughter ]
But the pandemic --
I was on another show,
and when it stopped,
we sort of went to this.
You know?
We went the other way.
We phased down to nothing.
And then that show
got cancelled during it.
And I did an article, and I sort
of cried about it, but...
[ Laughter ]
The thing is, it's so dumb
Like, shows get canceled
all the time.
If it was great,
it would still be on.
It's like, "I don't even kno
what I'm talking about."
[ Laughter ]
So they cancelled it.
But I stayed on,
I did monologues and stuff
just waiting for --
you know, just as an outle
to -- to --
just for no reason,
just 'cause I was in my house,
and I like to write jokes,
and I had some writer
from the show, and I was like,
"Let's write a few things,
and that was fun.
Because we couldn't do anything.
And then after like months
the Governor comes out,
"Hey, the first tier,
things are gonna open up."
We're like, "Here we go."
"First tier we're gonna open
some rock quarries,
archery repair shops,
caterpillar sanctuaries."
I'm like, "I'm sorry.
What's going on?
Anything I do?"
"No, that's gonna be a while."
So --
So I was glad about that.
-You got to --
You started doing
what you called the nonologu
on Instagram.
Was it nice?
Because again, you've obviousl
worked, you know, for cabl
channels, for network channels
where you have a censor
who is telling you
if you ever cross a line.
When you're doing an Instagram
video, no one's there.
Do you ever remember
some of the times
that you received heat,
be it at "SNL" or elsewhere?
-Oh, God, yeah.
Well, one time at "SNL" --
And what you're saying is true
when I do a nonologue at home,
there's no rules.
I don't work for anyone.
It doesn't matter.
No one's like, "You know, we
kind of work with that person.
You know, we actually --
They're one of our sponsors,
which, understandably,
is in every business.
But when it's just yourself,
I don't give a [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
So, I do it.
And one time on "SNL" --
[ Giggles ]
Oh, a couple people remember
No?
[ Laughter ]
So I did it "In and Out" list.
So one of my first ones
was with Dennis Miller.
So he was at "Update."
This is right up your alley.
"Update," Dennis Miller.
-[ Laughing ]
I was next to him,
doing my little bit.
And I was like, "What's in
You know, going to bars.
What's out?
Not going to bars."
You know, that kind of stuff
It was sort of middling.
But one of them, I said,
"What's in?
Not enunciating,
so the censors can't catch you
What's out? Goin' out after th
show and getting some [bleep
[ Laughter ]
And that, as you know, at "SNL."
So, Andrew, I think was hi
name -- he was a redhead.
-Yeah. Andrew Brewer?
-Yep!
Yeah, Brewer.
-He was very cool,
and he goes "Spade, come on.
Like, he was always like,
"Come on, man.
You're just
making my job tough."
And I go, "I'm not gonna
really say it."
And he goes, "We will lose s
much advertising if you say it
We saw it at rehearsal,
so when we go to air,
if you say it, this loses
$20 million in advertising
If you say these three letters
If you say these two letters..."
And I'm like --
and Dennis Miller goes,
"You're gonna blow it, spudly.
[ Laughter ]
And so, I said it,
and it got too big a laugh
and I was like, "Grr!"
And then Dennis goes,
"That's the news."
And he goes,
"You're done, dude."
[ Laughter ]
And so I walked out.
And then I see Brewer,
and he goes...
And I go, "I don't know.
Just see what happens."
And then, I think it was okay.
-You got away with it.
-I just saw this --
I just realized you were there
on the other one.
-Yeah. I was there.
I want to point out
I co-wrote this sketch.
"Sean Penn, Celebrity Roast.
I was Sean Penn,
and you played --
you played Owen Wilson.
But I did not --
this was your idea
was what you wanted
Owen Wilson's nose to look like.
Who is someone that you and
are both huge fans of.
-I love Owen Wilson
and love Sean Penn.
Did you do a Sean Penn nos
or is that just you?
-No, I just did -- I think
that's just my nose, yeah.
We, famously,
have the same nose.
-So, I do Owen Wilson.
Yeah, we had it look like
a weiner, you know?
Like, that was
sort of the funny bit.
And then, I think you,
as the writer heard --
'Cause I heard about it,
so you heard about it,
that it, again, it was probabl
Brewer going, "Come on.
You guys can't make it look like
exactly a weiner."
And so, prosthetic-wise --
So, after dress,
something happened where tha
note got lost in the shuffle
which sometimes happened
in the chaos,
and so I'm going on
to do the bit, and I'm like,
"Oh, we never changed it!"
-[ Laughs ]
-And so, I might've been telling
you because you were right there
and you were the boss
of the sketch.
So we just did it, and then it
was, like, on the Internet
because they go,
"Wow! How can they do this?"
[ Laughter ]
It was funny, though!
"How's it going?"
-It was great.
-I definitely think, like,
the prosthetic guys
were so happy when you gave them
the initial note of, like,
"I want it to look like this,"
and they really went for it.
-They did.
Got everyone in trouble.
I thought it was --
It was just --
Prosthetics just are off
on their own,
and then when you give them
note, they're, like, excited
like, "Watch how perfect
we can do this."
-I saw that you just bought,
at auction,
Chris Farley's
old Harley Davidson.
Did people know
that you were the person
who was bidding on it?
-No, you know, I --
A guy came to me and said,
on my DMs, he says --
Which I answer, sadly.
And he said, "I have
Chris Farley's old Viper,"
which I remember.
And I was like,
"That old black Viper he had?"
And he got a ticket in it,
I remember.
And he said yeah, and he showe
me a picture of the thing
in "The Enquirer"
where he got a ticket.
I was like yeah, and he goes
"Do you want to buy it?"
And I was like,
"I kind of would like
to have something from Chris
You know, just be interestin
to have, I don't know."
And I love cars.
So he stalled or something
And then, his brother goes
"His motorcycle is for sale,
his Harley from Chicago.
And it's on an auction.
You should get on it tomorrow.
And I was like,
"Oh, that would be cool."
I'll put it in my house.
My house is a mansion.
[ Laughter ]
See all the hardwood floor
Like, I can just park it
by that little plant.
[ Laughter ]
Rrr rrr!
So -- or put it in the tree.
So, it's basically
the Cecil Hotel here.
So, anyway, I go
on this auction -- chk chk -
and I'm getting outbid,
and so it gets up and gets up,
and I finally win it,
and then his brother goes,
"I can't believe
you beat Timmy Meadows."
And I go, "That's who
I was going up against?
You should have told me.
We could have figured it out
We didn't have to get it up.
So anyway, I go,
"Oh, don't tell Tim I got it
He'll feel bad."
So a minute later, Tim calls me,
"Hey, he just told me
it was you."
[ Laughter ]
And he goes,
"Would you sell it to me?
Can I get it from you?"
And I was like --
He goes, "You know,
I grew up in Chicago with him.
I love motorcycles."
And I go, "Yeah, okay."
Because, you know, he didn't
have anything of Chris's,
and I thought, "You know,
he's a Chicago guy,
and it was from Chicago,"
so I gave to it Timmy,
and he sent me some of
the money, so it was great
[ Laughter ]
-Just some?
-No, he did.
He sent me all of it,
but what -- then my guy says -
I go, "Timmy's gonna
send the money."
And then they said, "Oh."
And then later they go,
"You know, it's way more
than that 'cause of
the auction fees
and all the taxes --"
And I go, "Yeah,"
and they go, "Tell Tim."
I go, "I'm not telling Tim."
[ Both laugh ]
Like, I call him,
"Hey, Tim, eh...
It's just a couple grand,
but if you could --
I can meet you on La Cienega."
[ Laughter ]
I sort of --
I would hate for him to see this
and send me money.
This would be horrible.
Worst-case scenario.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm glad --
That's very kind of you.
That's a really nice outcome
And congrats on the show.
It's really fun to see you b
able to tell jokes on TV again
Thanks very much
for being here, Dave.
-Love it, Seth.
Miss you.
Haven't seen you in a while.
And take care and keep doing
a good show, buddy.
-All right, be well.
"The Netflix After Party"
is streaming now.